KIM JONG-UN IS THE BIG WINNER.
>> NANCY PELOSI TALKING ABOUT
THIS LETTER THAT THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED OUT HIMSELF.
AMONG THE OUTREACH THOUGH IS A
FUTURE LINE IN HERE, IF YOU
CHANGE YOUR MIND, HAVING TO DO
WITH THIS MOST IMPORTANT SUMMIT
PLEASE DO NOT HESITATE TO CALL
ME OR WRITE.
THE WORLD AND NORTH KOREA
PARTICULARLY HAS MISSED A
OPPORTUNITY IS TRULY SAD MOMENT
IN HISTORY.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
TOM, YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW THIS
ALL CAME DOWN TODAY.
>> I THINK THE BASIC POINT HERE
IS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
LEAVING CLEARLY AN OPENING TO
TOWARDS CONTINUING THE SUMMIT ON
JUNE 12th AS PREVIOUSLY BEEN
ARRANGED.
IN MY OPINION THAT WILL HAPPEN.
I THINK YOU SEE COMING FROM
BEHIND THE SCENES HERE IS A
PRESSURE CALCULATION ON THE PART
OF THE CHINESE TO SEE HOW FAR
THEY CAN PUSH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I THINK THE CANCELLATION WAS
DIRECTED AT BEIJING AS WELL.
THE SECOND PART KIM JONG-UN
RECOGNIZES THE SYMBOLISM OF THE
ATTENDING OF THE SENATE IS AS
COMPLICATED AS CONCESSIONS HE IS
EXPECTED TO MAKE.
THINK THE SUMMIT WILL GO AHEAD
ON JUNE 12th.
>> TO THAT POINT A FOX NEWS
ALERT HERE.
IN THE LAST FEW SECONDS NORTH
KOREA SAYS TRUMP'S DECISION TO
SCRAP THE SUMMIT IS NOT IN LINE
WITH THE WORLD'S WISHES.
NORTH KOREA SAYS THEY'RE WILLING
TO RESOLVE ISSUES WITH THE U.S.,
KA * ACCORDING TO STATE RUN
MEDIA. THIS DEVELOPS BY THE DAY,
BY THE HOUR.
PHOLGY.
>>
MOLLY.>> I THINK IT'S DISAPPOINI
MOLLY.>> I THINK IT'S DISAPPOING
BUT NOT COMPLETELY SURPRISING.
YOU SEE NORTH KOREA AND THE U.S.
PRETTY FAR APART.
NORTH KOREA PROPOSED WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN IN PAST DECADES.
A PLEDGE TO EVENTUALLY
DENUCLEARIZE.
THE U.S. SAYS THAT WON'T WORK
ANYMORE.
WE WANT IT UP FRONT,
ACCOUNTABILITY AND A TIMELINE.
WE HEARD COMMUNICATIONS HAD
BROKEN DOWN.
I AGREE WITH TOM IT'S NOT THE
END OF THE LINE BUT A
NEGOTIATION PROCESS.
WHAT IS INTERESTING ABOUT THE
REPORT HERE IS PEOPLE WERE
CAREFUL WHETHER NORTH KOREA
WOULD SAY WE'RE WILLING TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN AND WORK TOWARDS IT
OR IF THEY WOULD RESPOND WITH
THE MISSILE TESTS AND OTHER
BELLIGERENT ATTITUDES.
IT'S A LONG BALL GAME STILL.
>> AMY WE'RE GETTING FROM THE
NORTH KOREANS THAT NORTH KOREA
IS WILLING TO TALK TO THE UNITED
STATES ANYTIME IN A RESPONSE OF
THE DECISION TO PULL OUT OF THE
SUMMIT SAYING THEY WANT TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUES.
YOU HEARD SENATOR MCCONNEL SAY
THE NEXT STEP IS NORTH KOREA'S
AND THIS IS IT.
>> I'M FASCINATED TO WATCH THE
WAY IN WHICH AMERICANS ARE
REACTING TO THIS.
TAKE AWAY THE BACK AND FORTH
HERE IN WASHINGTON.
IN POLLING WHAT WE HAVE SEEN THE
LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS IS ACROSS
THE BOARD THIS IS REPUBLICANS,
DEMOCRATS, AND INDEPENDENTS WERE
GIVEN THE IDEA OF A SIT DOWN
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND KIM
JONG-UN HIGH MARKS.
THEY LIKED THE IDEA.
IN THE LAST CNN POLL PEOPLE SAW
THIS AS TRUMP'S MOST POSITIVE
MOVE AND HE RECEIVED HIS HIGHEST
MARKS.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC OVER ALL IS
SAYING I LIKE WHERE THIS IS
GOING, WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THIS, LET'S TROY IT.
IF THIS GOES WILDLY OFF TRACK OR
THE SUMMIT DOESN'T HAPPEN OR
MORE SABER RATTLING FROM NORTH
KOREA OR SOUTH KOREA DOES
SOMETHING THERE IS A CONTINUING
SORT OF CHAOS, DOES THAT THEN
ULTIMATELY IMPACT THE WAY THAT
VOTERS NOT ONLY SEE THE
PRESIDENT BUT ULTIMATELY THE WAY
HE HANDLES ANY OTHER FOREIGN
POLICY OR FOREIGN POLICY CRISIS?
>> RIGHT.
TOM, QUICKLY WRAP THIS UP.
>> YES, I THINK THE NORTH
KOREAN'S KNOW THEY HAVE A
INTEREST SKPEUGT DOWN AT THE
SUMMIT.
BEIJING WANTS THIS.
THEY WANT TO SEE IT TRUMP IS
MALLABLE.
THE LETTER SUGGESTS HE IS NOT.
THE MESSAGE WE SEE FROM THE
NORTH, THAT'S AS NICE AS IT GETS